long ago there was a vast multiversal War
countless unique timelines battled each
other for Supremacy nearly resulted in
the total Destruction of well everything
but then the all-knowing eagle remains
emerged bringing Peace by reorganizing
the Multiverse into a single timeline
this sacred timeline now he who remains
protect and preserve the proper flow
of time for everyone and everything
we write our own destiny now
who is he
I was told that everyone who works at the TVA was
created by the timekeepers they're all variants
If anyone was ever gonna make it back from the void I suppose it was going to be you well
you know one man's void is
another man's piece of cake
everything you're holding on to
I know how it ends
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel and
Kevin feige just hold a huge presentation for
Loki season 2 as well as a bunch of other upcoming
Marvel Series so we'll break it all down one of
the biggest surprises was how much stuff they're
going to release later this year and how it all
fits together let's just say Marvel and Star
Wars fans are going to be eating good later
this year if you're new to the channel I'll be
doing videos for all the Loki episodes just like
my season one videos I'll add a link for those
in the description below and I'll remind people
before season two gets started we're still
in the middle of that special Guardians of
the Galaxy giveaway too so I'll name another
winner later in the video today I'm going to
give you a look at three Marvel series for Disney
plus as some of you may remember last year when
Sam Jackson uh came to talk about his new show
secret Invasion but Kevin feige revealed that
Loki season 2 episode 1 will release October 6th
there are six episodes just like season one it'll
progress pretty much like season one did and Lead
directly into Deadpool 3 with Wolverine in the TVA
and Avengers 5 King Dynasty obviously that's
going to be a all about the Council of Kings
or the dynasty of Kings as king the Conqueror
called them an Ant-Man the WASP quantumania
the whole reason why Avengers 5 is called Kang
Dynasty is because Sam Wilson's Captain America
will fight the Council of Kings the dynasty
of Kings the beginning to touch the Multiverse
there have been a couple minor changes with what
Marvel is doing since my last Loki video earlier
this year it's been a while since I've done a Loki
video mostly schedule changes they pushed a lot
of stuff they delayed a lot of things I know there
are a billion questions about what's going on with
Kang and all the Kang variants during Loki season
2 like Victor timely because of what's going on
with Jonathan majors in real life so I'll try to
address that as much as I can during the video but
it is a developing situation so that's why you
haven't heard a lot of people talking about it
just because we don't know how that's going to go
down in real life but as of me posting this video
like look at the date that the video was posted
Marvel said that they don't play plan on making
any changes to Loki season 2 episodes for the most
part regardless of what winds up going down either
good or bad one of the reasons why they're waiting
till later in the year to release Loki season 2 is
just to give themselves a little bit more time and
there's a writer strike going on right now too so
if they do make minor changes it would probably
just be to like a Loki season 2 post-credits
scene Jonathan Majors is in a good portion of the
Season as a few different variants of Kang that
Loki and Mobius are hunting down that's what
the whole Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
post-credits scene was all about it was literally
a scene that they just copy pasted from the Loki
season 2 episodes shapes our lives but perhaps
we can shape it during that you can see the Loki
has taken Mobius into the 1800s chasing after the
Victor timely variant of Kang from the comics who
was trying to alter Earth's history by introducing
the concept of time travel around the same time
to make more time travel jokes Thomas Edison
Nikola Tesla were introducing the concepts of
using electricity to power things and you can tell
based on Loki and mobius's conversation that this
is happening very early in the season because
at this point Mobius still doesn't recognize
Kane just looking at him because normally if you
knew who Kang was you'd be like oh man there's a
variant of King we need to stop him what you
made him sound like this terrifying figure
yes and the whole idea at the beginning of season
two is that Loki has come back into this rebooted
version of the timeline where a different variant
of Kang grows up created the TBA and everybody
is a new version of the character basically
because they're from a new timeline so only
Loki and Sylvie remember the events of season
one so at the beginning of the Season Loki has
to do a speed run explainer for everything that
happened with Kang in the Kang variants that's
why Mobius doesn't recognize Kang isn't afraid
of him the way that Loki is and Loki's trying
to tell him this is just another variant who's
very dangerous and just pretending to be from
the 1800s His Banner reads Victor timely and his
astounding temporal Marvel as in Marvel Comics
the name Victor timely is also referenced to the
real world origin of Marvel Comics a long time
ago a young Stan Lee was hired by Martin Goodman
who owned timely Comics which then became Atlas
Comics and then became Marvel Comics there's been
a lot of references to the real world origin of
Marvel Comics and a lot of the other Loki season
2 scenes in different episodes as well too but
Victor timely was a version of Kang that decided
the smartest way to get rid of the Avengers was to
start in the past and he traveled back to 1901 in
Wisconsin and set up this business that he wanted
to use to take over the planet what they're doing
with the character during Loki season 2 is a bit
Divergent from what they did in the comics they
changed a bunch of stuff because in the comics
eventually it was his son Victor timely Jr then
Victor timely III in present day that wound up
fighting the Avengers during the post-credits
scene in Loki season 2 this is just meant to
be a variant of Kank from a different universe
and it's just this Victor timely version that
they're going up against they're not going to
be facing like the next 10 generations of this
variance of Kang all the other different kings
that they face during the season and Kang will
be in many different episodes as many different
variants will all be from different universes and
it seems like he's showing off a primitive time
travel device using old-timey technology and he's
basically pitching the audience about controlling
time which is what all the Kang variants are doing
or trying to do he says time is everything it
shapes our lives but perhaps we can shape it
then they reveal in the crowd Loki and Mobius or
they are on a TBA assignment with Loki Just Deadly
afraid of him in trying to convince Mobius what
a threat Kang variants are like that's in that's
the guy I've been telling you about and Mobius
not really understanding why he's so dangerous
because he's from the rebooted timeline and has
no memories from the events of Loki season 1 and
I think the idea here is that a version of Kang
just went back into the pass in the late 1800s and
is trying to change history from this point in the
past in part of Loki season 2 will be them trying
to stop Kang variants and him trying to convince
them about the dangers of the king Multiverse war
and what's really going on with the Council of
Kings fun fact to miss minutes in this trailer
Miss minutes is played by Tara Strong in the Loki
series but also Tara Strong guest starred as a
version of Mainframe during Guardians of the
Galaxy 3. she's using a completely different
voice which says a little bit different but you
can kind of tell that it is Tara Strong because
if you're asking about the truth of it well I
can't tell you don't hesitate to let us know
how we're doing that's gonna remain top secret
Kate actually tweeted last week that she wanted
to do like a feature-length horror movie with
Miss minutes and I'm like oh I am in that would
be so much fun because everyone's saying that last
scene is giving them nightmares like thanks Tara
Strong thanks for the nightmares I'm like oh I
guess I've done my job well then I've already
done a couple other Loki season 2 trailer videos
from earlier this year with a bunch of different
footage so I'll link those in the description
below during the big Marvel presentation Kevin
feige also dropped a new Echo trailer they didn't
post it online so if they do wind up doing it I'll
do a full breakdown of it but he also revealed
that during November right after Loki finishes
they're releasing all the echo episodes all six
of them at the same time binge style at the end
of the month Daredevil and Kingpin are both
big characters during the episodes they're in
a lot of the Season way more than you saw of them
during the Hawkeye series and during Spider-Man
no way home the episodes are meant to directly
set up the events of Daredevil Born Again those
episodes will drop in 2024. they also ended that
new trailer with a shot of Kingpin with an eye
patch over one of his eyes which is meant to be a
reference to the comics after Echo shoots him the
way that she did at the end of the Hawkeye series
it didn't kill him if people were confused about
that Kingpin is still very much alive it's just
it for a lot of the echo series he'll be wearing
that eye patch and then by the time he gets the
Daredevil board again he'll be healed the other
big thing that just happened while I was making
this video is that Aubry Plaza dropped either a
big spoiler on purpose or not on purpose called
the dark hole Diaries here I'll do a video for
that in the next day or two the other big thing
they just announced is that she would tell igeofor
who is Baron mordo in the doctor strange movies
in the MCU has joined the cast of Venom 3 as
a main character so we'll try to do a video for
that as quickly as possible too congratulations
Harris beats Frank 6304 hopefully we'll get some
jet ski references in Deadpool 3. please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can get your
contact details everyone click here for that new
dark hole Diaries video I'll update the link as
soon as I post it and click here for my brand new
Captain America New World Order First Look video
at a bunch of new scenes and all the characters
thank you so much for watching watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!